Now that we looked different scheduling policies, let's discuss
the implementation issues of these scheduling policies in an operating
system. One possibility is, the operating system can maintain
a global queue of all the threads that are runnable
in the system. And, what these processes might do
is. When they're ready for work, they'll go to this
global queue and pick the next available thread from
this queue, and run that on itself. And the way
we organize the queues is orthogonal to the
scheduling policy itself. But if the policy is
something like FCFS, it makes sort of logical
sense to have. A global queue and let the
processes pick from the queue the head of
the queue is the earliest arriving thread and therefore
first come first serve policy we use this
global queue policy. This global queue becomes very infeasible
as an implementation vehicle. When the size of
the multiprocessor is really big. Because then, it's
a huge data structure that all these guys
have to access centrally and so on. So typically,
what is done is to keep local queues
with every processor. And these local queues are
going to be based on affinity. And the particular
organization of the queues. In each of these processes.
These local queues for each of these processes
is going to depend on the specific policy that you're
going to use. So, if it is last processor, or
is it, is it fixed processor, is it a
minimum intervening, or is it minimum intervening plus queuing?
All of those things will decide how these local
queues are going to be maintained. But important point I
want to get across is that. In implementing the scheduling
policies, you have to have a ready queue of threads
from which the processor will pick the next piece of
work to do. And the organization of these queues will
be based on the specific scheduling policy that you might
choose to employ for the scheduler. And it might be
that processor p2 runs out of work completely, nothing in
its local queue. In that case it might pull its
peers' queues in order to get some work from other
guys and run it in that processor. Now
that's something that might be done and that is
what is called work stealing in the scheduling
literature. So that might be something that is commonly
employed in a multiprocessor scheduler. So I mentioned
that the. Way these queues are organized is based
on policies that scheduler picks which might be
affinity-based or might be fairness based and so on.
But in addition to the policy specific
attribute, it might also use additional information
in order to organize its queue In particular, a priority of a thread is
determined by three components. Now one component
is the affinity component assuming it's an
affinity based scheduling policy. But in addition
to that, it might also use additional information.
So for instance every thread may be born with a
certain priority, so that is the base priority that. A
particular thread has when it is started up, and as
I mentioned, it might depend on whether you know they
usually give a huge amount of money you know, to
run this particular thread. So that is the base priority
that you associate with the thread, and, and, of course,
then you take the affinity into a, into account. And in
addition to that, there is age coming in. And this
is sort of like a senior citizen discount. If a, if
a thread Ti has been in the system for a long,
long time, you want to get it out of the system as
quickly as possible. So what you do is equivalent to giving
a senior citizen discount. You boost the priority of the thread
by At certain amount, so that it gets to, to be
at the head of the queue, and it will get scheduled
on the process of p2. So basically, the
priority attribute is what determines the position in the
queue in the particular thread. And as I said,
three attributes that go with it is a base
priority that you may associate with a thread,
then it is. First created, the affinity it has
for a particular processor, and also the senior citizen
discount that it might give to a particular thread
depending on how long it's been on the system.